alors bonjour autour de la planète à
tous nos amis qui nous écoutent en ce
moment en direct nous sommes ici à
montréal
il est 11 heures 14 minutes nous avons
même quinze minutes nous avons quatre
minutes de l'auteur réalisateur ne vont
en principe commencer à 11h11 mais vous
n'auriez pas voulu assister au spectacle
ici un studio de préparation salut oui
oui demande dans l'est ben non ils ont
refusé nous avons deux one missed
receive allemands ils ont dit non pas
question
ce qu'ils contrôlaient les eaux gimeno
celui qui paie l'addition aps la semaine
prochaine et notre assisté second départ
marie claude simard on a les deux
patrons et l'impasse et toutes les
choses n'ont jamais c'est bon alors il
s'assistent mutuellement j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas la journée de
la femme internationale de la femme on
peut tout dire tout est permis car
qu'est ce que j'ai dit voici les deux
plus belles fameux toujours notre ami
disons ici à radio canada international
vous pouvez toujours là me anne-marie
vont également et depuis dans la section
c'est le service des espaces autochtone
de radio canada qui est avec nous un
ancien collègue de travail qui tient à
être présente avec sienne suis toujours
là faisait vue bon j'ai l'air ancien
mais sinon alors la question cette
semaine télé discipline faudrait
bon on arrête là pardon je dois appuyer
sur un bouton
il ya des indices qui vaut d'accord êtes
vous prêt pour le début d'émission oui
alors bonjour tout le monde autour de
leur colère aujourd'hui les américains
méritent et le système de santé
universel comme le nôtre alors c'est une
question amusant pour attirer nos
internautes vers le menu de mission qui
porte sur les désirs de beaucoup
d'américains de se doter d'un système
comparable aux assauts du canada on va
essayer de montrer aujourd'hui qu'il ya
des lacunes et on n'est pas les seuls à
dire même des américains en eau place en
place est très au fait c est ce que vous
avez eu vent de la déclaration du vice
président américain dans une radio poste
de radio alaska où et quand on va
montrer la vidéo puis vous peut-être
paraphraser les propos du vice-président
américain fait en regardant la vidéo sur
notre grand écran magique qui si on a
reproduit en français des propos
unilingue anglais du président ou
vice-président futur président peut-être
et voici ce qui se dit il s'en est pris
donc aux lacunes du système universel de
canadiens centre de soins de santé
je veux pas mâcher mes mots pouvez vous
s'il vous plaît compléter la
conversation la description de ce qu'il
a dit alors moi j'entends savez entre où
je suis à washington l alaska il ya un
endroit appelé les canada je n'ai
probablement pas besoin de rappeler aux
gens de l'alaska les lacunes d'un
système de santé nationalisée parce que
c'est notre voisin et on en voit les
résultats tous les jours mais c'est au
même niveau que les précédents des états
unis 1,6 m alors il dit faux pas s'il
faut pas adopter ce système là puis si
on adopte pas le système proposé par
trempe tout va s'effondrer aunès qu'il
explique pourquoi il ne faut pas
l'adopter non
c'est ça c'est ça qui est un des temps
alors nous on va le faire quelles sont
quelques-unes de ses lacunes ont fait le
tour de table
qu'est ce que les américains devraient
éviter s'ils devaient copier l'exemple
canadian marivaux aïe aïe
qu'est-ce qu'il devrait éviter aux deux
épaules temps d'y penser d'avant prenait
de court ce qui est critique et
principalement autour du thème du
système de santé canadien c'est le temps
d'attentes
quand on va quand on demande shiloh j
quand on a besoin d'une chirurgie puis
si ce n'est pas très urgent on n'est pas
envoyée en chirurgie rapidement donc ça
prend beaucoup de temps mais je dirais
que c'est un peu c'est ça la principale
très mal aux doigts très large
je dirais que ce qui semble ennuyer
beaucoup les professionnels de la santé
est en fait c'est un peu la cause de la
lenteur de la tente c'est qu'une
bureaucratie derrière tout ça qui est
vraiment lourde alors les médecins les
infirmiers
il faut vraiment qu'ils fassent des
tâches administratives ou qu'il ya tout
un réseau complexe de décharge
d'information qui ralentit beaucoup
l'offre de soins je pense qu'il faudrait
c'est très belles observations les eaux
gimeno je ne sais pas comment ils sont
un cas par rapport à la quantité des
médecins ici au canada
ça c'est lent parce qu'elle n'a pas
beaucoup
puis les gens les médecins qui qui sort
comment ce travail et dans le système
canadien cerveau aux états unis parce
que sont beaucoup mieux payés alors les
problèmes c'est la quantité des
professionnels est ce que les états unis
ayant quantités assez importantes pour
faire la même chose et nous habitons
épicerie en fait je pensais à
l'informatisation parce que c'est vrai
que quand on arrive chez le médecin m
des fois il sait pas il s'y connaît pas
notre dossier connaît pas notre réalité
faut qu'il cherche il n'a pas le temps
tout est compressé 1 fois les vite vite
vite ils ont tant que patient avoir par
jour
des fois tu voudrais passer une demi
heure avec lui mais il n'a que dix
minutes à te consacrer finalement tu
sors d'un été hyper frustré études il a
pas le temps de savoir qui je suis et
qu'est ce qui m'arrive c'est ça le
problème a fait un agent sinon on a un
rapport très étroit avec le médecin n'a
pas trait 3v ici alex des spécialistes
moi je suis allé une fois un problème de
la peau j'avais tâche dans la peau qui
je suis rentré puis messier mais m'a
même pas regardé aux yeux il m'a dit
c'est quoi ton problème ce n est
regardée gésir bedache b comment
sont-elles lui le regardait son
téléphone ah oui ils sont payés à l'acte
c'est un problème ça il faut qu'ils
voient beaucoup de patients pour pouvoir
payer les factures
si moi je considère que c'est un
problème n 1 je sais mon observation
personnellement j'ai eu le même problème
que vous récemment avec un spécialiste
pour un problème de respiration puis
mème pas garder
et puis il est jeune il me demandait
pourquoi ça allait pas j'imagine plutôt
médicaments il a il me dit mais vous
n'avez pas vu les actions
je me suis dit mais quelle qu'elle
manque de patience
bastien qui vient vous voir et même déjà
quand on arrive ils devraient déjà avoir
l'une dossier savoir qui on est quel est
notre passé médical au moins pour avoir
une idée de qui il s'adresse
en dix ans oui un fait c'est que je vois
qu'elle la plupart d'entre vous avaient
eu des mauvais ces canadiens
moi je sais pas encore je suis comme l'a
peut-être l'exception qui confirme la
règle
mais à toutes les fois que je me suis
adressé à mon à mon médecin de famille
ou à des médecins spécialistes ou que
j'ai amené mes enfants dans le système
de santé canadien
j'ai été vraiment très bien servi si
vous voulez maintenant on veut dévoiler
l'identité mystères de notre invité une
spécialiste de la question qui va nous
aider à répondre à cette question qu'est
ce qu'il faudrait éviter aux américains
si vous voulez imiter le système
canadien à quoi ils devraient songer
avant de se commettre
alors voici notre invité il s'agit de
madame johanne castonguay un homme
castonguay
bonjour alors je vais faire un rapide
tour de table ici je me sens les
questionner et ils ont souvent la bonne
réponse donc on en profite
qui est cet invité mystère de quoi
va-t-elle par des qui est elle bien
c'est assez c'est assez remarquable
c'est une spécialiste qui a analysé
récemment c'était la commande qu'il y
était passé le système de santé au
québec
le travail des médecins et s'est
intéressé à la question des de
l'innovation en milieu de santé c'est
une technologie de façon de faire c'est
ce qui permet de mieux traiter les
patients de réduire les coûts enfin en
théorie en pratique comment ça se passe
alors madame castonguay est économiste
et directrice de recherche à l'institut
de recherche en politiques publiques et
coauteur d'un rapport qui vient d'être
publié il ya quelques temps il ya tout
ici - du cirano un castonguay
alors on va essayer de comprendre ça
veut dire quoi
l'enjeu de l'innovation en milieu
hospitalier
par rapport au travail quotidien du
médecin pouvez-vous nous y allait d'un
exemple de ce qui devrait apprécier
mieux fonctionner py qui dans les faits
fonctionne pas oh la la c'est une très
très grosse question que vous me posez
il ya plusieurs composants si en fait je
sais pas si vous voulez que je commence
par le fait de la difficulté d'intégrer
les innovations si vous voulez qu'on
parle ce qui ne fonctionne pas mais en
fait dans glee j'dirais dans un premier
temps un jeu direct et ça c'est
peut-être plus à en réponse à la
critique des américains envers notre
système il ya aucun système de santé sur
la planète qui n'est pas critiquée par
c'est la population où sa population ou
la population auquel le système
s'adresse là si on veut il ya aucun
système qui est parfait et c'est
extrêmement difficile de les comparer
parce qu'aucun d'entre eux ne pas du
même point de départ
alors si on critique notre système on le
critique mais pas question d'aller dans
bien des hôpitaux ou des organisations
de santé aux états unis on serait très
peu impressionnés et probablement qu'on
trouverait que notre système est
extraordinaire
je pense que les verts c'est aussi vrai
parce qu aux états unis on trouve toute
l'équipe d'organisation possible de s'en
fie donc est bon la problématique de
l'innovation essentiellement est liée au
fait que on y très très bon au niveau
des bébés découverte
des publications nos chercheurs en santé
les chercheurs canadiens et
particulièrement les chercheurs
québécois ont d une excellente
performance en terme de découvertes de
publication de performances de référence
et que j'étais la grande difficulté
c'est que on n atteignent pas le système
de santé
et quand on dit l'atteignent pas le
système de son innovation c'est que le
système de santé ne les intègrent nous
les appliquerons et pourquoi
essentiellement c'est le corps c'est le
corps parce que les les acteurs du
système de santé nous conte les outils
pour les intégrer nos champions sont ne
chante pas responsabilisés pour les
résultats de saint pée par rapport aux
ressources dont disposent ils sont
responsabilisés pour nick ou contre et
puisque c'est l'objectif premier qu'on
leur remet en question évidemment en
assurant la meilleure qualité possible
mais ils sont vraiment leur premier
objectif c'est de contrôler les coûts ça
ne naissent pas intégrer les innovations
et d'ailleurs ils ont pas les moyens
pour le faire
donnez nous un exemple pratique au
service à l'urgence par exemple on se
présente avec un problème respiratoire
qu'a vécu et le médecin a le choix des
traitements l'innovation ou la routine
donnez-nous l'exemple bon en fait ça
serait pas tellement le médecin comme
l'hôpital l'hôpital
dans un cas assez précis avait le choix
entre utiliser caisse en fait l'option
d'utiliser était ce leur monde les tests
respiratoires qui sont normaux je dois
tout traditionnelle qui leur permettrait
de définir si c'est un virus ou une
bactérie qui est présente et ces tests
le sont en fait à partir de les cultures
et les résultats ça tient à peu près à
partir de 3-4 jours excusez-moi de 48 a
maintenant un nouveau test qui est
disponible et avec cette technologie là
on peut obtenir les résultats à
l'intérieur de deux ans donc le la
compagnie qui commercialise la caisse
fournissez tesla et l'équipement à un
hôpital qui nous sommes en fait et avec
des chercheurs avec des personnes de
laboratoire on essayait de voir si
l'obtention des résultats permettait de
d'obtenir des meilleurs de diminuer les
hospitalisations de donner les meilleurs
médication c'est à dire que lorsqu'il
s'agissait de d'un virus de ne pas
donner des antibiotiques et donc ne pas
avoir d'impact aussi sur la résistance
aux antibiotiques et caetera et caetera
et les infecter d'autres personnes
pendant les 48 heures exactement où le
besoin d'isoler les patients qui coûte
beaucoup plus cher lorsqu'on y met dans
un environnent
isolé bref on a lu cette capacité là
mais même et donc le test a
effectivement démontré qu'on était
capable effectivement obtenir les
résultats plus rapidement mais étant
donné que chaque département sont isolés
et que l'hôpital dans son ensemble nos
ponts à démontrer ou à essayer d'obtenir
les meilleurs résultats possibles compte
tenu de son budget dans son ensemble il
ya personne que changer l'endroit où est
effectué le test du que l'hôtesse 30e
allemands étaient effectués auprès des
patients hospitalisés
seulement ou et encourager les gens les
médecins à l'urgence d'hospitaliser les
patients pour pouvoir effectuer une
thèse et une fois qu'on a eu une
nouveauté si on continue à faire auprès
des patients hospitalisés puis on peut
changer le moment où il allait lire les
résultats puis changer ou non ou réagir
par rapport à leurs prescriptions
initiation donc avec le résultat que
même s'ils ont obtenu les résultats plus
rapidement il n'y avait absolument aucun
changement et donc on disait bah écoutez
ça ça aucun résultat alors non on a
d'autres postes technologiques qui cote
1 oui en fait je me demande si c'est une
question philosophique qui est derrière
c'est cette espèce de des complexes
réalité du système de santé ce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui fait en sorte que les
gens travaillent individuellement et
puis le fait qu'il travaille
individuellement
parce qu'ils sont pas encouragés à
travailler en équipe fait en sorte que
le résultat est celui qui vous venez de
décrire
effectivement le fait que les gens
travaillent et résident en chine au
département par département va avoir un
gros impact sur sur cette intégration
des innovations ne s'est pas juste parce
qu'ils sont organisés de cette façon là
tout le système contam est organisé
comme sur le système d'information sont
organisées comme ça donc mêmes
tout au niveau de la gouvernance dont
qu'ils ont pas d'encouragement à essayer
d'obtenir le meilleur résultat à
l'intérieur de leur établissement et en
utilisant les meilleurs et collaborer
entre les différents départements pour
être capable d'obtenir le plus de
services ou de bénéfices possibles
compte tenu des ressources à la
disposition chaque département et c'est
d'atteindre la réduction des coûts et de
remplir leur mission qui est d'offrir
des services au moindre coût possible
plutôt que de dire obtint offrir la
meilleure valeur compte tenu des
résultats et dollars spawning oui alors
maintenant que vous avez observé tout ça
donc vous vous savez où est ce que ça
mène comment faire changer les
mentalités et comment faire changer tout
ça dans la réalité au quotidien
d'abord les problèmes
vous avez parlé plutôt de ce que je
dirais comme que vous avez tous
identifiés sont beaucoup des symptômes
un saut bon évidemment ça peut pas
l'être quantité de médecins
l'informatisation ou qui le paiement à
la khl
quand on m'a parlé de des temps
d'attentes qui dont on observe une
démocratie qu'est lourde chute et ça
c'est vraiment des symptômes et ce
concert au niveau des bébés des patients
lorsqu'on se présente auprès du système
ainsi concerne l'informatisation puis
les mécanismes de paiement
je suis entièrement d'accord avec lui je
voyais revenait au niveau de la quantité
des médecins par exemple c'est pas vrai
que le moins de médecins qu'ailleurs au
contraire
augmenter la quantité de médecins comme
colas et en terme de comparatifs par
rapport aux autres provinces canadiennes
et même par rapport à d'autres
juridictions
on est très bien positionné alors on
peut pas dire que c'est le nom de
médecins qui qui qui notre problématique
les problèmes ou qui moi je
j'aurais trop solution initiale et si
des solutions que je répète souvent et
c'est ce qu'on a trouvé comme aussi et
aime les grands obstacles à
l'amélioration à l'innovation
il ya trois éléments le premier c'est le
système d'information dont je parlais de
l'informatisation
on n'a aucune information sur comment ça
nous coûte parc
comment ça nous coûte pour traiter un
patient et tant qu'on n'a pas cette
information au losc c'est très difficile
de prendre les bonnes décisions à savoir
c'est une technologie vont changer le
vent nous permettre de mieux traiter
contenu nos dollars ou quoi que ce soit
parce qu'on le prend et qui nous permet
de suivre les résultats par type de
patients ou licou partir de patients
donc on peut pas comparer et sa mesure
d'ailleurs c'est très difficile de
prendre les bonnes décisions alors c'est
pas je prendrais de dire que de
responsabiliser année du dut ou un autre
mais en tant que société on doit exiger
de nos gouvernements qui misent la chute
dans un premier temps est souvent
extrêmement c'est pas les politiciens
ça fait plusieurs amis qui savent qu'il
faut qu'ils fassent ça et n'ont même de
commissions politiques qui leur ont
recommandé de passer à 7 au
développement de ces informations lors
de ce système là mais c'est très peu
sexy d'un point de vue politique alors
l'allemand va pas se faire élire parce
qu elle décidé d'informatiser le système
de santé
alors ça c'est une des difficultés
qu'ont encore quand tu sais la première
la deuxième je dirais que si le système
de paiement ou de financement sont
orientées sur le contrôle des coûts puis
qu'on donne des budgets qui sont qui
sont par service et non par patient on
ne responsabilise pour les individus
rapport aux résultats au patient donc il
faut vraiment responsabiliser les
prestateurs changer mon mode de
financement de sorte que le mode de
financement de vielles ou de paiement de
vie incontrô entre le payeur et le
prestataire ne sort que ils doivent
athènes appelle un certain résultat pour
recevoir une enveloppe d'un million de
troisième point essentiel le dernier
point essentiel c'est la
décentralisation c'est à dire que si
toutes les décisions sont prises à la
tête et qu'on enlève toute autonomie
capacité de prendre des décisions
c'est extrêmement humble et démotivant
et c'est complètement la relève de
responsabiliser les acteurs pour les
résultats de leurs prestations
mais mme castonguay on sent que vous pas
vous parler du coeur ça semble vrai
ils message à passer très c'était
c'était direct et bien et ça nous aura
on étendait pas l'arabe comme à table un
plaisir de vous parler et on voudrait
invitera à la prochaine chicane d'accord
johan castonguay économistes et
directrice de recherche à l'institut de
recherche en politiques publiques
là on est bien vite est remarquable
c'est un coup de chance
écouter un petit question ici on parlait
des tentateurs brièvement rapidement
question sont onze pays les plus
industrialisés au monde dans lequel on
inclut canada où nous situons nous sur
la liste des pays où lille où les choses
sont les plus hauts niveaux de
rencontrer un médecin système de santé
sur contre 11
enfin il le premier c'est le plus rapide
en 10e 10e huitième 8e 9e et 7e
allemagne premières sont très efficaces
en doutez canada 11e
si ça vous intéresse là on a une hyper
dias une page de tam-tam canada qui est
porte sur que sur soi s'ouvre une
enquête internationale n'agit je parle
par expérience j'ai passé une journée à
l'hôpital on m'a jamais vu alors à la
fin de la journée après y avoir passé
sept ou huit ou dix heures j'en avais
ras-le-bol j'ai quitté la même chose
avec moi ma fille a cassé la jambe
on a passé sept ans avec elle ils ont
des styles et nous on a fait le triage
mais nous en dit une fois qu'un jour je
suis allé en fait j'ai retourné à la
maison on a dormi à la maison on est
d'aller voir les
mais cliniques privées là le lendemain
il nous a envoyés directement dans une
attelle hôpital ils ont mis les les
plâtres moi je vous suggère de faire du
tourisme pas sexuel mail tourisme
médical
pourquoi femmes sexuelle on peut faire
les deux remarques et non pas n'en
voulons pas encourager ça jamais je me
glisse médicales n'ont pu écouter mais
tourisme et du casque un sérieux bond de
50% depuis 2010 du nombre de canadiens
qui vont faire du tourisme médical on
est maintenant rendu à 60000 canadienne
par années 60 et pensez-y 500 millions $
si vous voulez en savoir plus
cuba médical louis et qu'on a d'ailleurs
pour ça là-bas très bon même si simple
des familiales au lien avec ça nous
vient tout de suite après celle de la
présentation de cette vidéo qui est
préparé par radio canada international
avec klein sont s'il vous plaît allons-y
c'est le luxe on a le son on l'avait
tout à l'heure oui je suis arrêté taux
de réussite avait pourtant belle au
studio il est autant d'encre concentre
sa route vraiment atteindre 8,0 mais
avec le taux de réussite si on est pour
les familles vivent et y en a plusieurs
qui ont été dits
on aurait dû y aller pennavien s'ils
n'en font pas au canada c'est peut-être
partir pour trouver encore la méthode
est la solution il le remet un coup
remet petit à sow c'est pour ça que le
supposions ou réputés année des années
sont ici nous médecins lui ont fait des
examens visuels à toutes les
on y dit où en est rendu là progression
on nous dit service com de points
communs si ça dégénère plus je n'étais
pas une canne blanche
vous avez droit service à la maison mais
on n'a pas d'autre solution qui nous
aidera pas un problème à cuba c'est
qu'il nous offre une solution
c'est d'être tapés aguirre on reproche
qui était perdue parce qu'ils étaient
perdus été perdu par kehl et ses deux
sont membres
on peut prendre et les années donc
toujours certaines méthodes pour stopper
l'évolution de la maladie
voilà ça c'est un exemple 60 beaucoup
d'autres un autre exemple à la main en
fait ma mon exemple viennent du mexique
parce que vous savez je suis mexicain
d'origine
donc ma tante elle a eu un accident
cérébro et puis elle a été envoyé dans
un hôpital au mexique les premiers
traitements ont été faits là mais quand
elle est sortie du coma il n'était plus
capable de parler adéquatement puis elle
avait beaucoup de difficulté à argas
voir et puis on lui a suggéré d'aller
voir un groupe de médecins cubains
quéven clinique à mexico et donc ils
s'installent dans des grandes villes
donc ils font ça à partir de l'ambassade
cubaine à mexico donc un lien direct
avec le gouvernement de casser ce talent
là il faut une première évaluation puis
ensuite si tu veux continuer son
traitement
tu peux aller sur l'île et puis
continuer le traitement à des coûts plus
élevés évidemment parce qu'il faut que
tu peux être au logement etc
mais je vous dirais que suite à ce
traitement
ma tante et fait un bond extraordinaire
au niveau de la de ses facultés ray
acquise je dirai pas ce qu'ils avaient
perdu
le sage de la parole et puis en revenant
de ces traitements l'acteur est
traitement qui se fait nulle part
ailleurs parce que c'est eux qui ont
développé ce traitement avec la
recherche est donc c'est extraordinaire
le changement un cube heure française
cyclhad à côté on les applaudit
surgissement des mais on ne bouge pas ce
que beaucoup d'entre nous les admirons
ces cubains qui en aucun cas l on a
coupé les vivres pendant des dizaines
d'années
du côté des américains voient ils font
des recherches et on applique la
recherche on la regarde pas de loin en
disant oui ok qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
l'onl appliquer leur système de santé
leur système d'éducation est remarquable
innovation c'est le mot que je pense
les erreurs médicales voulez vous qu'on
en parle beaucoup on cache la chose
c'est beaucoup ça vous fait pas que
seront cinq questions on remue méninges
quels sont les risques si vous allez à
l'hôpital à l'urgence qu'il ya une
erreur médicale
je veux pas savoir et engage un sur dix
donc 10 % disons que j'ai légèrement
parce que c'est beaucoup ça des 10% 1
patient sur dix une erreur médicale 1er
3 sur 10 sont des 1
même très basses opinion moi croix sur
dix a maintenant moi je dirais un sûreté
des noms pour ça on en a sur dix il faut
que je change
[Rires]
elle dénie pas c'est un sosie
c'est avec l'inde 1 pour cent pour cent
c'est que marie cause c'est toujours
celle qui est la plus proche en fait
toujours autant parler des radis la 60%
de bonnes réponses jusqu'à maintenant
non on exagère un peu mais la bonne
réponse et c'est pas beaucoup c'est 6%
des visites à l'hôpital se termine par
une surprise là ça va plus les erreurs
médicales
il va vouloir ouvrir l'état
voilà ça c'est noir voici mettre dans la
réalité on fait en jette la lumière sur
la sphère où voilà avec p 106 bouteilles
c'est l'autre had à droite son numéro 8
6 me suis tu rentres à 33 et yanni à
l'hôpital après qu'ils ont vu leurs
titres venus chercher
et pour une raison ou une autre
information que j'avais communiqué aux
ambulanciers et à l'hôpital ou aux
hommes qui étaient là qu'il avait eu un
2e investi quelques hôpitaux n'ont pas
semblé comprendre que c'était vraiment
la réalité une mauvaise interprétation
est mauvais diagnostic udp baer a été
témoin d' erreur dans le système de
santé en alberta dans l'ouest canadien
lorsque son mari était souffrant il ya
quelques années qui a caressé un carré
d'art pendant sept heures dans le
département
médecine familiale alors j'ai questionné
pourquoi maintenant et non en urologie à
bien s'il n'y a pas de place à bord 6 6
puis alors à tous les jours je répétais
aux personnels qui étaient là qui avait
eu un avc et qu'il avait prêtés pour
l'avc
le médecin qui est étonnant me dit vous
savez très bien madame pourquoi vous
avez amené votre avatar ici c'est que
vous souffriez de brûlantes et puis que
vous ne pouviez plus gérer le
comportement agressif de mon mari les
facteurs de risque les hôpitaux
canadiens sont multiples dangers
potentiels par exemple la fameuse
fatigue de compassion au sein du
personnel hospitalier qui est en
croissance en ce moment on parle de
l'épuisement profond une érosion de
l'incident n'est plus un physique
émotionnel françoise mathieu et
psychothérapeute et spécialiste en
trauma est en bonne entente chez les
aidants codirectrice également de tende
il s'agit d'une firme d'experts conseils
en mesure de compassion et belote dans
l'ouest canadien avec la surcharge de
travail et les qui compte justement les
aurait contacté quelques uns qui fait
des grès des dons d'organes des
décomptes et la génétique
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus large on
imagine ce reportage est beaucoup plus
long que vous ne l'avez entendu bien sûr
la version intégrale sur l'image de
tintin y en a dans cette semaine
sauver des drôles de visages autour de
la table l'usure de compassion nous
sommes impatients c'est triste mais je
me pose la question comme un vivre ça à
tous c'est à dire ces gens là ces gens
là tous les jours sont confrontés à des
cas difficiles à des cas particuliers
avec cas unique
oui donc j'imagine on ne leur donne plus
le temps aussi exactement
donc ça doit être difficile cela vous
exactement je leur lève mon chapeau
mais en même blanche il faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose si vous êtes vraiment les
gens ramassent à l'hôpital quand j'avais
16 ans et je ne savais pas ce à quoi le
système de santé une opération avec puis
de les faire bière gentil comme tout ça
fait toute une différence quand on est
traité comme un être humain fait toute
une affaire
mais inversement aussi des fois les
patients ne traite pas les infirmières
comme des êtres humains et ça aussi
c'est dur pour le moral qui ont abondera
continuer à parler pendant des heures
on l'a tous vécu des situations des amis
des choses comme ça j'aimerais qu'on
conclut l'émission concluant toujours
intéressant de montrer quels genres de
bons coups n'a fait cette semaine dans
la travers menons nous ferons aussi il y
en a plusieurs rien à 4 sur la page de
tam-tam canada cette semaine dont le
beaucoup de marie-jo ben c'est notre
dernière vidéo de la journée alors nous
à metz ne peuvent pas prendre congé
encore
après ce qui sont déjà prêts à partir on
la voyait l'image on descend on va voir
le reportage de marie ce marijuana dans
les aliments un pot-au-feu difficile à
avaler au canada et à l'interview un
spécialiste de mort cité de dalhousie et
on va l'entendre justement faire cette
entrevue parler du défi de contrôler ou
non l'utilisation de la marijuana mais
yann des matches où on s'inquiète un peu
par rapport à la santé des enfants
on n'est pas trop sûr des effets qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire avec la marouane
comme poids du commun c'est bien parce
qu'on comprend bien quelques semaines
dans l'esprit de la du projet de loi c
on ne préfère pas légaliser des produits
comestibles à base de cannabis
par contre avec le marché noir ces
produits existent ici le produit légal
voix est plus cher ben on risque de voir
le marché reprend d'exploration et on
pourrait avoir plus de produits comme un
site est disponible sur le marché noir
chaque semaine le projet ces gamins qui
est au plus haut et complet qui prend 12
i dont compagne de ce spécialiste
disponible sur la page de tam-tam canada
vous avez l'air assommé par je me pose
tellement de questions ce matin on
parlait de la marijuana comment est
serré
elle sait
disponible légalement disponible
également pour les jeunes à partir de 18
ans l'ontario 19 ans puis chaque
province va prendre une décision
concernant l'âge mais ces jeunes 18 ans
parce que le cerveau continue de se
développer à cet âge là cependant des
jeunes de 18 ans qui veulent fumer mais
la marijuana aujourd'hui oui ils peuvent
le faire même si c'est pas les gars
c'est tout
mais en fait ce sera une question
d'éducation tout afin de comme
d'habitude que la même chose avec la
cigarette avec quoi que ce soit la
section éducation mais ceux qui veulent
en fumée vont de toute façon trouver le
moyen d'en fumer
et puis les hôtes bah écoute et
éventuellement ils ont utilisé leur
jugeote pour se rendre compte que voilà
cent sur les routes du québec et du
canada à partir du 1er juillet de l'an
prochain si cette loi va de l'avant
l'égalisation de la vendent de la
marijuana au canada ou pas de l'avant la
vente et la consommation
tout est légal
alors merci beaucoup à n'arrivons d'être
venu cette semaine toujours un plaisir
jour parlement martinez avoue également
même si beaucoup revenir la semaine
prochaine et c'est la jsk lorraine marie
claude simard a bientôt on va se revoir
après l'émission va discuter choses
sérieuses léger mello merci beaucoup
bonne semaine